the two-day royal drama began and
apparently
ended with the marginalized but popular
prince hamza
still at center stage on monday evening
king abdullah dispatched his uncle to
intervene
a short time later prince hamza signed a
letter saying
we must all stand behind the king in his
efforts to protect
jordan there was no mention of the
investigation
announced the day before the government
had accused prince hamza
of plotting with foreign entities to
destabilize
jordan the surveillance intercepted
movements including communication with
foreign sides on a so-called zero hour
to trigger measures aimed at undermining
our stability
prince hamza denied the allegations he
said highlighting worries of government
corruption and failed economic policies
was the real reason he was warned to
stay silent
the turmoil within the royal ranks first
came to light
early sunday morning with a leaked video
message recorded from
inside prince hamza's palace he said he
was under house arrest
with no security detail and no internet
on monday he released an audio recording
saying
the chief of staff was threatening him
and telling him
to keep quiet
i am not going to escalate but i will
not buy myself by their orders to stay
at home
not to use my twitter or to be in
contact with people
and not to see my family what i've been
told by the chief of staff
is not acceptable under any
circumstances
prince hamza's audio recording was
shared widely on social media
many jordanians are feeling angry and
frustrated
over the deteriorating economy last
month there were protests
and dozens were arrested but dissent
within the royal family
revealed in real time was a new
phenomenon
i was surprised as everyone else with
this disturbing news
the news really caused pain to everyone
we wish for prosperity and progress for
jordan
and for the issues to be resolved as the
king called for within the royal family
the dispute among royal half brothers
may have ended
at least for now but concerns about a
deepening divide
and jordanian's economic plight won't be
resolved
so swiftly natasha ghanim al jazeera
amman